what's our guilty pleasure
hi i'm ashniko and today i'm going to be
talking to the love of my life my king
my queen the apple of my eye i'm going
to be talking to myself
hi hey baby
how are you
good
you look really good today
thank you i love what you're wearing
i love your vibes
you're really giving 10 out of 10
unhinged today
i really am i am unhinged hanging on by
the smallest thread
i haven't had a day off in
some weeks don't i know it
all right first question
what is your most annoying habit
woo boy scrolling on the internet that
[ __ ] is ruining my life
stop
scrolling on the internet i'm trying
it's so bad i'm [ __ ] trying we're
gonna take a little time to be nice to
our noggin
i love you um
question two what's the most star stroke
you've ever been the other day when we
saw avril lavigne at the vmas i love
april levine i know you do babe what's
our favorite avalavene song it's
caterboy obviously i also love
complicated though because
as you know life is good this is
complicated avril
we love you
next question
if you weren't singing what would you be
doing instead
if we weren't singing
you know that we would be larping oh
yeah full time what's your larping
character i'm a half elf yeah
our name is tourmaline moonblood that's
right
all right next question give me a real
juicy one okay okay what's your biggest
guilty pleasure
like
excessive porn watching
i don't feel guilty about my pleasures
we're proud i feel fine watching porn we
are proud of our pleasures do you have
any like tv shows that are guilty
pleasures for you
okay it's the office and sex in the city
when i'm really trying to
smooth brain
brain dead two brain cells fighting it
out in the boxing ring of my mind
turn off i feel that i feel that office
uk or us the u.s
i know i love michael scott but we we're
a sex and city lover definitely
are you a carrie i mean
i like to think that i'm a samantha but
we're a carrie we're a little terrible
she is annoying but if we're honest with
ourselves we're a little annoying we're
our own guilty pleasure honestly
who or what has been your greatest
inspiration i
i think musically for me it was m.i.a
first followed up by gwen stefani
when i was 11 years old when i got my
first when we got our first pink ipod
nano for christmas best day
oh what a day
santa claus really did the damn thing
that year we went on itunes and our aunt
downloaded mia bucky dunn gun heater
absolute heater it's one of the best
songs in the world oh yes
all right next question
what is your best party trick
we haven't been to a party in a while we
are surprisingly anti-social at parties
yeah
we are it's been so long i just don't
even remember what they're like that's
the sound of a good party baby our party
trick is probably oversharing
guilty
i think maybe it makes us more likable
that's debatable
next question no more oversharing please
which of your songs
is your favorite
i think it's probably daisy
realistically
when that blew up
what a fun day what a day
what a day yeah that was that was weird
so when did you first realize that our
baby was gonna be massive we knew that
day we were like this is the one she is
that
right here we just knew we knew we've
gotta go your taxi's here five more
minutes please
just me and you and the world watch so
nice
listen to a lot of house music drama
base i like guns and roses ac dc what
about like bieber ed sheeran i listened
to ed sheeran i listened to like
listen i was clubbing on i think it was
a friday and the only thing i remember
from the night is at four o'clock in the
morning i was crowd surfing the justin
bieber baby